In this segment, we
introduce a model
with multiple parameters
and multiple observations.
It is a model that appears
in countless real-world
applications.
But instead of giving you a
general and abstract model,
we will talk about a
specific context that
has all the elements
of the general model,
but it has the advantage
of being concrete.
And we can also
visualize the results.
The model is as follows.
Somebody is holding a ball
and throws it upwards.
This ball is going to
follow a certain trajectory.
What kind of trajectory is it?
According to Newton's
laws, we know
that it's going to be described
by a quadratic function
of time.
So here's a plot of such
a quadratic function,
where this is the time axis.
And this variable here, x,
is the vertical displacement
of the ball.
The ball initially is
it a certain location,
at a certain height-- theta 0.
It is thrown upwards.
And it starts moving with some
initial velocity, theta 1.
But because of the
gravitational force,
it will start
eventually going down.
So this parameter theta 2, which
would actually be negative,
reflects the
gravitational constant.
Suppose now that you do
not know these parameters.
You do not to know
exactly where the ball was
when it was thrown.
You don't know the
exact velocity.
And perhaps you also live
in a strange gravitational
environment, and you do not
know the gravitational constant.
And you would like to
estimate those quantities
based on measurements.
If you are to follow the
Bayesian Inference methodology,
what you need to do is
to model those variables
as random variables, and
think of the actual realized
values as realizations of
these random variables.
And we also need some
prior distributions
for these random variable.
We should specify the
joint PDF of these three
random variables.
A common assumption
here is to assume
that the random
variables involved are
independent of each other.
And each one has
a certain prior.
Where do these priors come from?
If for example you know
where is the person that's
throwing the ball, if you know
their location within let's say
a meter or so, you should have
a distribution for Theta 0
that describes your
state of knowledge
and which has a
width or standard
deviation of maybe
a couple of meters.
So the priors are chosen
to reflect whatever
you know about the possible
values of these parameters.
Then what is going to
happen is that you're
going to observe the trajectory
at certain points in time.
For example, at a certain time
t1, you make a measurement.
But your measurement
is not exact.
It is noisy, and you
record a certain value.
At another time you make
another measurement,
and you record another value.
At another time, you
make another measurement,
and you record another value.
And similarly, you get
multiple measurements.
On the basis of
these measurements,
you would like to
estimate the parameters.
Let us write down a model
for these measurements.
We assume that
the measurement is
equal to the true
position of the ball
at the time of the
measurement, which
is this quantity,
plus some noise.
And we introduce a model for
these noise random variables.
We assume that we
have a probability
distribution for them.
And we also assume that they're
independent of each other,
and independent from the Thetas.
It is quite often that
measuring devices,
when they try to measure
something multiple times,
the corresponding noises
will be independent.
So this is often a
realistic assumption.
And in addition, the noise
in the measuring devices
is usually independent from
whatever randomness there
is that determined the
values of the phenomenon
that you are trying to measure.
So these are pretty common
and realistic assumptions.
Let us take stock
of what we have.
We have observations that
are determined according
to this relation, where
Wi are noise terms.
Now let us make some more
concrete assumptions.
We will assume that the
random variables, the Thetas,
are normal random variables.
And similarly, the
W's are normal.
As we said before,
they're all independent.
And to keep the
formula simple, we
will assume that the means
of those random variables
are 0, although the
same procedure can
be followed if the
means are non-0.
We would like to estimate
the Theta parameters
on the basis of
the observations.
We will use as usual, the
appropriate form of the Bayes
rule, which is this
one-- the Bayes
rule for continuous
random variables.
The only thing to notice is
that in this notation here,
x is an n-dimensional vector,
because we have n observations.
And theta in this example is
a three-dimensional vector,
because we have three
unknown parameters.
So wherever you see a theta
or an x without a subscript,
it should be
interpreted as a vector.
Now, in order to calculate
this posterior distribution,
we need to put our hands on
the conditional density of X.
Actually, it's a joint
density, because X
is a vector given
the value of Theta.
The arguments are
pretty much the same
as in our previous examples.
And it goes as follows.
Suppose that I tell you the
value of the parameters,
as here.
Then we look at this equation.
This quantity is now a constant.
And we have a constant
plus normal noise.
So Xi is this normal
noise whose mean
is shifted by this constant.
So Xi is going to be a
normal random variable,
with a mean of theta
0 plus theta 1ti,
plus theta 2ti squared.
And a variance equal
to the variance of Wi.
We know what the normal PDF is.
So we can write it down.
It's the usual exponential
of a quadratic.
And in this
quadratic, we have Xi
minus the mean of the
normal random variable
that we're dealing with.
Let us now continue
and write down
a formula for the posterior.
We first have this
denominator term,
which does not
involve any thetas,
and as in previous examples,
does not really concern us.
Here we have the joint PDF
of the vector of Thetas.
There's three of them.
Because we assumed that
the Thetas are independent,
the joint PDF factors as a
product of individual PDFs.
And then, we have here the joint
PDF of X, conditioned on Theta.
Now with the same argument
is in our previous discussion
of the case of
multiple observations,
once I tell you the
values of Theta,
then the Xi's are just
functions of the noises.
The noises are independent, so
the Xi's are also independent.
So in the conditional universe,
where the value of Theta is
known, the Xi's are
independent and therefore,
the joint PDF of the Xi's
is equal to the product
of the marginal PDFs of
each one of the Xi's.
But this marginal PDF in
the conditional universe
of the Xi's is something that
we have already calculated.
And so we know what each
one of these densities is.
We can write them down.
And we obtain an
expression of this form.
We have a normalizing
constant in the beginning.
We have here a term that comes
from the prior for Theta 0,
a prior from Theta 1.
Here is a typical
term that comes
from the density of Xi,
which is this term up here.
So here is what we have so far.
How should we now
estimate Theta if we
wish to derive a point estimate?
The natural process is to look
for the maximum posteriori
probability estimate,
which will maximize
this expression over theta.
Find a set of theta parameters.
It's a three-dimensional
vector for which
is this quantity is largest.
Equivalently we can look at the
exponent, get rid of the minus
signs, and minimize
the quadratic function
that we obtain here.
How does one minimize
a quadratic function?
We take the derivatives
with respect
to each one of the parameters,
and set the derivative to 0.
We will get this way three
equations and three unknowns.
And because it's a
quadratic function of theta,
these derivatives will be
linear functions of theta.
So these equations
that we're dealing with
will be linear equations.
So it's a system of
three linear equations
which we can solve numerically.
And this is what is
usually done in practice.
A this is exactly what
it takes to calculate
the maximum a
posteriori probability
estimate in this particular
example that we have discussed.
It turns out as we
will discuss later,
that there are many interesting
properties for this estimate,
and which are quite general.